[موسيقى]
كل ما
أعتقد أنه يمكنك فتح الفتحة
أولاً وبعد
ذلك تم
فهم أصول Activ.com ، شكرًا لك
حسنًا ، سأقوم بإلغاء تنشيط الأصول الهادئة
بعد ذلك بقليل ،
وهذا صحيح تمامًا رسم مارك
ساشا تهانينا لقد كنا سعداء
جدًا للعمل معك خلال
الإطلاق
والإرسو  ثانيًا بين الحين والآخر ،
سنرى ثلاثة أعضاء جدد من الطاقم
في منزلهم للأشهر الخمسة القادمة
في الفضاء
هذا كل شيء
، وسأخرج من الأعمدة هنا
آسفًا ، وأنا أيضًا أخرج من الهدوء
غير مسموع
وها هي الفتحة  مفتوح 1208
صباحًا بالتوقيت المركزي 12 أو
1108 صباحًا بالتوقيت الشرقي بينما طارت المحطة
255 ميلًا قانونيًا فقط فوق
صربيا
وأول واحد عبر الباب ألكسندر
ميسوركين قائد سويوز
لجميع أحداث اليوم
هذا مرة أخرى  رحلته الثانية إلى الفضاء
الثانية على متن محطة الفضاء الدولية
خلفه مباشرة رائد فضاء ناسا جو أكابا في
رحلته الثالثة إلى الفضاء والمرة الثانية
كعضو طاقم طويل الأمد على
متن المحطة
وإحضار الجزء الخلفي من
المؤقت الأول  مارك فاندا عالياً في أول رحلة فضائية
له يشق طريقه إلى
محطة الفضاء الدولية لأول مرة على
الإطلاق ،
وبهذا عاد طاقم الرحلة الاستكشافية 53
بستة أشخاص كاملة والآن سيذهب الطاقم إلى محطة الفضاء الدولية.
وحدة الخدمة الروسية
وبمجرد الانتهاء من إعدادها جميعًا ، سنبدأ هذه
المكالمات الصوتية وستتمكن من
التحدث إلى الأشخاص مرة أخرى
في بايكونور
أم
أننا ننتظر فقط
اصطفاف أنفسنا
أم
لا ، نحن أيضًا سعداء جدًا
المحطة هذه هيوستن ، هل أنت مستعد
للحدث
محطة هيوستن نحن جاهزون
للمعرض 53 مرحبا بكم في حفل
بايكونور هذا هو مركز التحكم هيوستن ،
يرجى الاتصال بالمحطة لمحطة فحص الصوت
هو سرقة القوات البحرية مع
زملائك وعائلاتك وأصدقائك في
بايكونور ، كيف تسمعني أسرق ،
لقد جعلناك بصوت عالٍ وواضح
أنك جميعًا تبدو رائعًا هناك
وسنبدأ الحدث
ثلاث سنوات يا أبي ،
هل الجو دافئ هناك
جيدًا؟  نرى أننا جميعًا دافئون هنا ،
استمروا في ذلك ، استمروا في ذلك ، شكرًا لك ،
أحبك
فقط تحدث فقط
كيف تشعر هناك كيف
نجوت من خلاله
يسعدني
كل التوفيق لك ولك
ولباقي الطاقم ،
شكرًا لك يا جدتي ولك أيضًا
ضع علامة على أن هذا جولس ،
مهلا ، كنت أتوقع سماع المزيد من اللغة
الروسية ،
ما الذي قلته للتو
2 يا له من إطلاق جميل
يفتخر به  أنت
وفريقك يا إلهي ، لا أعرف ما إذا كان أي شخص قد سمع ،
ولكن آه عندما كان من المفترض أن نكون هادئين
وعاملين واقتربنا من
المحطة ورأيت الأشعة الشمسية من النوافذ
، فذهلت واشتعلت فهل كل شيء على ما يرام
سأل مركز مراقبة المهمة إذا
كان كل شيء على ما يرام
لم نكن نعرف خلاف ذلك ، لذلك كان
كل شيء جيدًا
ولكن آه أنا فخور جدًا بك كل يوم
كان ذلك مذهلاً ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك ، إنه لأمر مدهش ،
أنا سعيد جدًا لأنك موجود هناك
أحبك عزيزي مكان رائع
أحبك يا سيدة رائعة جدًا ،
أهلاً ، مرحبًا ، إنه رائع ،
آه ، كيف تسير الأمور هناك ،
إنه أمر رائع ، أنا أه على الأرجح
كل شخص آخر هنا تجربة ، أنا
الشخص الذي يحبون
التنقل من أجلي حتى يتمكنوا
من التأكد  أنا في المكان المناسب دون أن
أطفو بعيدًا ،
لذا فإن التجربة جيدة ولكن
الطفو هو نوع من التكافؤ ، هل ستقول إن
قدرتي على الطفو الآن هي دون المستوى ،
أود أن أقول إن التحكم في الطفو
ضعيف ، وسأتعلم بسرعة على الرغم من
ذلك  الآن بعد أن وصلت بالفعل إلى هناك ،
ما هو رهانك على عدد فقاعات الهواء
التي يمكنك وضعها في فقاعة ماء ،
ولا توجد فكرة ، نعم ، لا توجد فكرة ، سأقوم بتوضيحها فقط
وسنكتشفها ،
يا رب ، كيف حالك
جيد  كيف كان
غدائك ، أعني أنه كان رائعًا حقًا
مشاهدته ولكن
كيف كان شعورك من الأعلى  كان هناك
أه مذهل ، أعني أنها كانت رحلة سلسة للغاية
، وكان كل شيء أه كنا
مدربين جيدًا لدرجة أنني تأثرت تمامًا ،
ولكن
كيف نجح كل شيء ،
ورأيت القمر خارج النافذة ، هذا هو
أول شيء رأيته و  ثم كان
القدوم إلى المحطة
رائعًا للغاية ،
أحبك أنت أيضًا
[موسيقى]
في كاليفورنيا ،
يا للملوثات العضوية الثابتة ، من الجيد أن تسمع
صوتك وبالطبع مرحبًا أمي الجدة
والجميع في كاليفورنيا الذين
يشاهدون ،
شكرًا على الدعم  كان الإطلاق
رائعًا ، لذلك
نحن
نبلي بلاءً حسنًا هنا ، مرحباً جو ، إنه رالف ،
أريد فقط أن أخبرك أنك تعلم أن
الإطلاق كان
رائعًا وبعد أن عدنا إلى الأسبوع
التالي بعد عودتنا إلى الفندق
عائلتك وأصدقائك  جمعت من أجل
نخب احتفالي
وكل شخص روى قصة جو
لذلك تعلمت
المزيد عنك خلال الـ 24 ساعة الماضية
جيدًا بهذه المعلومات ، أنا سعيد جدًا
لأنني خارج الكوكب ،
هذه قصص لا أريدها  اسمع
ذلك ، آمل أن آه
ما يحدث في بايكونور سيبقى في
بايكونور
روجر ذلك وشيء آخر قام ستيفن
بإنهاء الاحتفال
بغناء الأغنية التي اقترحتها
لذلك كان ذلك رائعًا ،
أنا متأكد من أنها كانت جميلة وأه سعيد لأن
المجموعة استطاعت  افعلها
وقد قضيت وقتًا رائعًا يا رفاق وأنا متأكد من أن
التسليم كان رائعًا ،
مرحباً يا مارك أمي أريد فقط أن أخبرك كم
نحبك وكيف حصلت على الدعم من الناس في
جميع أنحاء هذا البلد
وأحبك فقط
وآمل أن تشعر بكل شيء ،
يمكنني بالتأكيد أن أشعر
أن الصلاة ساعدتني حقًا وأشكرك كثيرًا يا
أبي ، أعتقد أنك بدأت تتحدث معي
أثناء حديثي ، تفضل ، قل ،
هل تسمعني ،
يمكنني أه نحن متحمسون حقًا  حول
وجودي هنا لرؤيتك
هكذا ، نعم يمكنك سماعي الآن نحن نشاهدك على التلفزيون وتأخرت بسبب التأخير ، لذا سأتوقف عن المشاهدة وأتحدث إليك فقط ،
إنه أمر حقيقي
اه وقت مثير بالنسبة لنا اه
نحن عاجزون عن الكلام على الاقل
انا نحبك و تا  أهتم
بنفسك ، سنراك قريبًا
وداعًا ، مرحبًا ، أحبك أيضًا
أتطلع إلى رؤيتك مرة أخرى ولكن
في هذه الأثناء سأستمتع حقًا
بهذا ،
مرحبًا جوها ليز ، أردت أن
أقول إننا فخورون حقًا  منكم جميعًا ،
شكرًا لكم على كل ما
فعلتموه من أجلنا ، ولقد استمتعنا بالموسيقى من أجل إطلاق
الإقلاع ،
شكرًا ليز ، أنا سعيد حقًا لأنكم استطعت
أن تشاركوها معكم ،
وأتطلع إلى ذلك.  مشاهدة
مقطع الفيديو الخاص بالإطلاق من
وجهة نظرك أحيانًا ، لذا
شكرًا مرة أخرى ، أتمنى أن يكون لديكم رفاق
رحلات آمنة إلى المنزل
وأخبروا الأولاد أنني قلت مرحبًا
وأه بالنسبة للطاقم ،
لقد عادت البحرية البحرية إلى بايكونور لقد فقدنا
آه كو لذا  سنختتم الحدث ،
شكرًا جزيلاً ، كل التوفيق في الطيران
الآمن وسنراك قريبًا هناك
وسأعيده إلى capcom في مركز
التحكم في المهمة في هيوستن ،
شكرًا لك رون ، شكرًا لكل من
جاء ورؤية
المحطة  هذه هيوستن أكر هي التي
تختتم الحدث شكرا لكم
نحن الآن نستأنف العمليات  نال الاتصالات الصوتية
لك